welcome back for national
and local cosmetic surgery specialist
sono bello supporting and empowering
women
is a daily lifestyle but they're taking
it up a notch during this time
partnering with dress for success
to help women after pandemic job loss
take a look
amy welcome to las vegas now hi how's it
going
good good i'm excited to talk to you
about sono bello's new partnership with
dress for success but first
let's introduce sonabella to all to our
viewers
obviously um absolutely so centobello is
a women-powered and women-focused
company on pretty much every level
we are the largest cosmetic surgery
provider in
the nation wow and run by women i love
that i love the sound that i was amazing
um so let's talk about the partnership
now what do you guys know a dress for
success
as a women-led company we understand the
unique challenges that women are facing
today
including the disproportionate job loss
due to the pandemic
so we're partnering with dress for
success to inspire hope and resilience
and spotlighting the work of women
leaders nationally and
as well as within the company that's
amazing and besides
you know all of the female power there
working for sono bella and all of the
females that
use your services you know how else are
you guys impacting women's lives
so well i mean as far as dress for
success goes
we're doing something called your hour
her power
where we are donating an hour of our
salary to help empower and support
uh women for the dress for success
excuse me ex dress for success campaign
um to uh give them the tools and support
they need to get back into the workforce
wow so so personally what have you seen
you know
what challenges have you seen women
going through lately especially during
this pandemic
no that's interesting so yeah women have
disproportionately been affected by this
pandemic
uh to the point of i mean last september
865 000 women
were laid off due to the pandemic which
is four times the number
of men that were laid off due to the
pandemic in december 100
of the workforce um that was laid off
due to the pandemic was women so
i mean it's obviously disproportionate
so we really want to get out there and
support women to
um to get back into the workforce
as well as continue to to manage their
home
responsibilities which is really a lot
of the reason why they've been pulled
away
now i know the the majority of your of
your clients at sonobella are women
so how do you guys on a day-to-day basis
you know inspire hope and resilience
for your clients you know we do it um as
a company we do it every day
you know our patients come to us for uh
newfound
self-confidence or confidence that they
have lost over the years and
you know cosmetic surgery gets this sort
of um
it gets this sort of idea that it's a
vanity thing but
really what we're doing is reinstilling
their self-esteem and giving them their
self-confidence back by
giving them their best body today we
talk about it our mission as a company
is to transform lives and we do that in
so many different levels
um one being giving them their
self-confidence back and
being able to rejoin the workforce you
have to walk into an interview
comfortable and confident and this is
the huge um
this is this is a huge initiative of
what we do for our patients every single
day so partnering with dress for success
for doing it with for women who are
uh not necessarily looking for cosmetic
surgery but
looking to get back into the workforce
it just goes hand in hand with what we
do every single day so we're already
naturally passionate about this
such a great partnership to help support
dress for success with sono bello you
can donate
one hour of your pay to the organization
just head to sonobelo.com
dress for success to get involved
kendall i'll send it to you